good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Monday
yikes hope everyone had a great weekend
I did Jax did you I did have a great
weekend because it was the Super Bowl
it's Harry's birthday weekend
however I'd be remiss devastated and
heartbroken and lying if I didn't
mention the neck of it all you guys were
with me on Friday as I struggled through
that episode it like took me out this
weekend I was in so much pain I'm on the
mend and I'm so much I'm feeling so much
better today still not 100 but it's so
crazy like it's crippling it was
crippling littered there is nothing
worse than having like a thrown out back
neck like I could I could literally do a
whole podcast on it because if you've
experienced it you know how truly
debilitating it is no you've never
experienced what I've experienced I
because
no because I've never experienced what
I've experienced I throw my back out
before like the way I felt yesterday and
today is like how you feel when you
throw your back out like very very
inconvenience pain Etc the way I felt on
Friday
there are no words
and you know Harry deserved more than
that you know it's his birthday today it
was his first birthday yeah but mommy's
feeling it's a national holiday mommy's
feeling better today and I will break my
back every day for him like I was
getting him in his pajamas which is an
Olympic sport and I had been feeling
better and then I was feeling worse well
what's on the docket for Harry's big day
I cannot believe my son is one years old
I'm like emotional they really do they
grow up so fast I wish she would grow up
like a little faster so we could walk
and we have to carry him everywhere but
like
time just flies when you're a mother
it's so true we just have a special day
planned at home we have balloons we have
cake just cuteness family time cake did
Harry get chocolate or vanilla I think
vanilla with chocolate icing I don't
know Harry I'm not so particular so it's
kind of just like do your worst yeah
like make a cake
do a flip right but it's all blue for my
little boy oh my God is so it's like you
blew this blew that um but it's gonna be
pretty low-key because he's only one and
he won't remember it and it's really
then it's for you know mama and Mama
just wants low-key so yeah
um well it's basically a national
holiday here at the toast Harry when you
watch us in like 10 years we love you so
much like obsessed with you you're the
greatest thing ever I'll be the best
birthday I would love you to the day I
die always and forever anti-coya he's
not watching this because it's like he
doesn't really like our show honestly
respect he's not the target demo if I'm
being honest honestly I see so many
babies watching the toast like people
always are tagging us in their stories
like the babies are enthralled but I
think it was like maybe he would watch
this episode because he hasn't seen you
but when we were trying to get him to
watch it and we were right there oh yeah
like I don't think he'd want to watch
Miss Rage with Miss rage
I would be no he would look at her and
be like do a flip when she yeah yeah
you're just sitting here early yeah like
you're gonna make me watch this
pre-recorded nonsense
oh well
honestly I know it's a Super Bowl and we
have so much to discuss I'm wearing my
Super Bowl hoodie where'd you get that
it came in a PR package yesterday a lot
of really cool merch for Ben from like
Michael Strahan's new like merch company
um and I thought this was so cute and
appropriate for the toast it is I know I
almost wore my red the bar sweatshirt to
celebrate the chief's uh Triumph but you
know
I can't wear it every day I know by the
way I almost wore one today it's really
no like I could wear one tomorrow and
I'm sure people are like you do wear it
every day you guys but like we really
can't like wear it every day no I know
like you'd think we own the company I
know for how much we're Shilling it we
don't but we do own Spritz Society
spritzociety.com I believe we have a
code toast still active always active
always that's what I think yeah did you
enjoy a nice pizza with the Super Bowl
last night I did I got a lot of good
snacks um actually we had to order our
snacks on go puff because Ben went out
to Duane Reade and as he was walking in
the place was being uh robbed
and people were screaming and so Ben
just like turned around and left
um he's okay and I believe everyone is
okay I think it's just like
you know New York teams yeah jeez so I
didn't get like me I didn't get my
proper selection of snacks because like
you know and isn't that the real shame
yeah the pharmacy is like they've got
tons of options gopuff has a ton of
options too but not as much as a grocery
store I have to be honest I ordered
extra backup snacks on go puff yesterday
and some Spritz and
I got everything and like I didn't even
need that much so now I just have
everything I got Chesters unopened I've
got Doritos unopen I've got rolled gold
unopened okay let's talk about rolled no
no
sorry Rolos I thought you were talking
about Rolos Rolos are like the most
under appreciated snack of all time
they're so good
agreed sounds like you weren't gonna
agree no I was just gonna like do
something that you and Ben would do like
start a conversation that like Ben would
start you want to hear it of course
would you consider Rolos a snack
good question that is a very good
question
um that's it that's an interesting point
I guess like would you consider a
Hershey Kiss a snack no yeah it's a kind
of it's a sweet treat yeah yeah no okay
okay okay okay such a good point Fire
Point and you know I believe they have
new packaging where they have like a
like a bag of unwrapped Rolos not the
same oh that's crazy talk yeah there's
something about like peeling it back the
foil like a gift having to work for your
role exactly otherwise you're just a
monster
shoveling them in and then like your
hands get all sticky and God forbid the
bag reaches the temperature where they
start to meld together anyone else's
husband do this or just like person that
they know like whenever we get candy
that's like sour fruity like we got
nerds like anything that's even remotely
sweet like boom it goes in the freezer
like the second my husband does have
chocolate oh that's weirder no what you
said was weirder really yeah yeah
because like people like they make
Snickers ice cream ice cream yeah but
like why do I want to break my tooth
like a chocolate is meant to be
creamy delicious soft why am I in the
tooth breaking business now no and I I
understand almost like putting it in the
fridge like to keep it a nice
consistency when it's chocolate
because you know you live in the
cupboard a little too long it's hot you
forget to turn the air on Boom it's a
soup no I you
easy
oh my God you're at a loss it just
shouldn't be so hard
I mean that's my feeling about life like
life shouldn't be so hard but yet here
we are everything is hard hey yeah like
where do you keep your chocolate
where do you keep your chocolate I let
us know in the comments growing up my
friend Alicia always like in her family
like they always kept the chocolate in
the fridge and I'm like this is so weird
but you know what it's actually not no I
understand their methods but I don't
want to eat cold chocolate
no me neither then you'd have to like
let it sit before eating and then if you
let it sit for too long but then you're
just delaying the chocolatey goodness
agreed
um so of course we have a great show
today we're going to talk about the
halftime show the game the commercials
the national anthem a lot to discuss I'm
so excited I was like really watching
very attentively at the game the
commercials everything so I have my
thoughts locked and loaded I have a lot
of thoughts I wasn't watching as
attentively because like there were
children like Harry's bedtime was in the
middle I watched the halftime show so
attentively though yeah but I definitely
missed a lot of commercials missed a lot
of game you know points were being every
time I came back the score was higher
and higher
um Donna Kelsey got what she wanted it
was a very high scoring game yeah and
both of her boys shined a hundred
percent the one shined a little brighter
yep
um and I had thoughts on that too
okay so let's get into
so let me see if there's anything else I
want to recap from this weekend Oh today
is my big day it's her big day you guys
uh it's Carnation Day it's literally
Carnation Day I have like I couldn't
sleep last night like this is something
I'm really nervous about
um tonight I am performing and walking
in Cynthia Riley's New York Fashion Week
show it is a night celebrating females
in comedy we're all gonna be like
wearing Cynthia's new line I had my
fitting on Friday I was like to me
there's nothing worse sounding than a
fitting like oh I have to fit into
clothes like nothing worse let me tell
you how I maybe I've been sleeping on
Cynthia Rowley because she decides for
women real girls
real women with like cellulite okay I
look I cannot wait for everyone to see I
have two looks I cannot wait I look
sickening like you saw it right like I
look amazing I mean that's what happens
when you buy clothes that aren't made
like
um
yeah like in sweatshops like no not even
like not even where they're made like
what they're made of like when they're
like top quality fabric Jackie I
am wearing top quality fabric I am
wearing top quality fabric I have I'm
like now you know what Jackie
goldsteiner was trying to say I look
amazing like it's amazing what the
difference is when you wear clothes that
feel like real Clothes Like These are
garments you know these are garments and
that's why like I mean a lot of clothes
are unnecessarily expensive but like
yeah in a lot of situations like you do
get what you pay for and like yep when
you're shopping
fast fashion I won't single anyone out I
won't yuck your yums like yeah it's
really a piece of garbage no and then I
went shopping in her store after the
fitting and I got some stuff for my trip
to Portugal like it was
I'm kind of like like a high-end like
designer girl now I love this journey
for you like you won't catch me on
Amazon just kidding you absolutely will
oh yeah no it's good to mix yeah you
can't have like a closet full of
designer clothes but like when you have
an event like
investing in real pieces even though and
you could wear it over and over you'll
have it for years to come I really hope
I get to keep them I just feel like I'll
go home in my outfit you know yeah and
then all of a sudden like sorry Cynthia
changed my number you know it's like
Cynthia's like oh hey we're sending a
messenger I'm like oh I moved or like
maybe maybe I'll just put it off until
my trip to Portugal because I'm gonna I
want to wear some of the stuff in
Portugal and then I'll be like going
back they're ready to be picked up
there's just like a little stain in the
armpit yeah no you send them for dry
cleaning you're a nice girl I'm a nice
girl yeah yeah so I'm like so looking
forward to tomorrow's show where I can
recap it like I have such a bit and
what's so crazy is like compared to like
audience sizes I've done like this is
it's nothing but it's you know it's a
new audience really fashion girly
what nothing
in terms of size
it's like I think maybe a couple hundred
I've done a couple thousand oh you know
it's a couple hundred yeah
and it's like you know influencers
tastemakers fashion fashion so like you
know fashion girlies they could be
you know yeah and I want
to I want to you know so much of Comedy
is making people feel like you know
relatable and have them feel like seen
and heard and I don't know I don't know
these girls
you know yeah well that's why you just
have to be yourself turdy yeah no and I
have some really good I was I wrote some
material over the weekend that I sent to
you and you thought it was good right
yeah that you sent to me yeah you said
or this yeah so I have some like good
fashion stuff like I'm excited this is
like it's so new and different for me
and I have like a bunch of people coming
who like I know I'm like you
better left so hard enough
is the snatcher going of course she
better be laughing like cackling like I
literally texted I texted everyone who's
coming like the tailors Ben sister
Maddie Margo I'm like you better
cackle like I want it to be fake Claudia
you need to fly Olivia in for the
occasion
I know because they're Olivia came to
like probably four of my shows total and
again yeah she came to the first one
ever
at City Winery which was more like a
dress rehearsal
she came to of course MSG she came to
Fort Lauderdale
maybe three
okay
is that it yeah
um and it was like the best shows ever
she has laughs like a hyena and it's
like so it's so empowering infectious
it's infectious but like to like usually
when you're on stage and you hear a
crowd laughing it's a cacophony of
laughter you don't hear one person
individually but Olivia has this really
special unique kind of like infectious
gorgeous laugh that you could hear in a
crowd of a million and to know that it
was my sister and like I know her laugh
is real it's not like like I know when
she laughs like that like when we were
kids it was the best I really should I
should fly her in yeah fire up the jet
fire up the jet I'll come to you I think
Levi and Kayla can take a couple hours
off from there from there Mama yeah she
needs a break
and Brew is the yoga always welcome no
no no he's not you should walk the
runway with Theo with Theo
work work
um so that's like what on my that's why
I'm like wearing my natural hair today
and I'm wearing like literally one like
tiny ounce of makeup because I have full
Glam after this I gotta you know get
going
how are you gonna wear your hair like
the usual turd of course like so nice
shout out to Cynthia letting me do my
own Glam so you know my regular I love
my my regular regular I'm not a girl who
experiments with Glam I know but now
that you're like wearing high fashion I
know like one of the outfits you're
wearing like I could see a bun
I could see a bunch too but I'm not
gonna do it but I could see it
okay one step at a time one step at a
time and there's no need to rush
learning to fly fly
um well speaking of singing I guess
that's one a great segue into one of our
stories all the performances from last
night yes so without further
do here are the fast five stories that
you need to know yeah you today's
episode super toast is brought to you by
honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart you know how
people say like oh my God how did the
cavemen do you know XYZ I think how did
we shop before honey because I used to
literally be shopping online and
Googling like promo codes Bloomingdale's
like so much and I've just copy and
paste a million different ones until I
found one that works honey takes seconds
it's free to download and install when
you use our link and then it will
literally be saving you money in seconds
so here's how it works you're shopping
at one of your favorite sites online
when you check out the honey button will
appear and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons that it can
find for the website that you're on and
if they find a working coupon you will
watch the prices drop and now it's so
exciting I've had it on my desktop my
laptop for like many years now it works
on iPhones too so just activated on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
I have loved shopping online on my phone
because it's so easy with like Apple pay
and now honey I don't have to miss out
on the savings because honey works on
your iPhone Safari too I have saved
money on clothes on makeup on food on
electronics pretty much everything like
stuff I buy for the studio equipment
obviously clothes for my house makeup
for my house it's everything so if you
don't already have honey you are
straight up missing out and by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
supporting the toast get PayPal honey
for free at joinhoney.com toast that's
joinhoney.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by ZipRecruiter so
you know in the spirit of Valentine's
Day it's so important to surround
yourself with people who you're
compatible with people you match with
and that's just you know obviously
relationships but working relationships
too you know gotta have the same
personality the same sense of humor have
a good chemistry
too bad there's not some sort of
technology that can easily find the
right person for you but if you're
hiring there is technology that can
quickly help you find the right person
for your open role zip recruiters
matching technology and right now you
can try ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast ZipRecruiter uses
matching technology to identify the most
qualified people for a wide range of
roles if you see it the one on
ZipRecruiter they'll make it easy to
send them a personal invitation so
they're more likely to apply to your job
if you want to really catch their eye
zip recruiter offers attention grabbing
labels that speak to job flexibility
like urgent training provided remote and
more find candidates you're crazy about
with ZipRecruiter we have used zip
recruiter many times over the years to
hire roles for the toast it is a great
asset a great resource Theo's getting
all excited he's like yeah Mom yeah Mom
zip recruiter your employer's uh
employers already love zip recruiter in
fact four out of five employers who post
on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself go
to this exclusive link to tri-zip
recruiter for free it's zip
recruiter.com toast that's
ziprecruiter.com toast ZipRecruiter the
smartest way to hire thank you zip
recruiter for sponsoring today's episode
for any and all of your hiring needs
make sure to check out ziprecruiter.com
toast
thank you charity you're welcome our
first story we'll talk about the game in
a second but Rihanna confirms she's
pregnant with baby number two after her
Super Bowl halftime performance so
Rihanna's expecting her second child her
rep confirmed to The Hollywood Reporter
after she performed at the Super Bowl
and nobody wanted to speculate as to
whether or not she was or she wasn't
because you know we're not judging the
bodies of new mamas no so I think a lot
of women or women we're women I think a
lot of people were like I am obsessed
with Rihanna like normalizing her
postpartum belly like yes months after I
still looked like that and I felt so
whatever and now Rihanna's doing it this
is amazing on the world's biggest stage
and when it was that it was very
empowering when it was a pregnancy like
either way it was even more empowering
no I know when she came out and she like
she literally like showed her belly okay
and and then like the p i was watching
and someone was like is she pregnant I
was like no she just had a baby like and
literally the entire time I watched it
not thinking like not entertaining the
idea that she was pregnant oh and then I
watched it and I was like
so I watched it so here's the thing I
don't think Rihanna meant for it to be
so confusing to us agreed I think she
meant to open it the camera zoomed out
she showed her belly she touched it a
little but then the camera zoomed out
back so fast she didn't like really grab
her belly it could have just been like a
Sensual Body touch like a dance move I
don't think so she did some other
Sensual Body touch yes I think she meant
to be like extremely clear but like it
got lost she was busy thinking about
other things the moves the choreo the
lyrics the vocals so she didn't do like
the most overt belly touch and then the
camera zoomed out really quick so we
were all like no one was really
commenting on like no like no one was
really commenting on like the
performance or the pregnancy until we
had some sort of
confirmation clear confirmation
um and then people started looking back
on the podcast she did right before
talking about how she's bringing a
special guest and of course there were
no special guests like you know spellers
it was her unborn baby which we love
um so I was pretty sure she was pregnant
the whole time like I don't know what a
postpartum belly looks like but I felt
like this belly was like really pregnant
looking like you know popped you know
like I don't know yeah
yeah I mean it could have been a
postpartum belly because like
everybody's like bellies are bellies and
they're gonna and belly's gonna belly um
you just said a mouthful right there
sister but then so I watched the whole
thing like not thinking that she was
pregnant thinking this was just like a
moment for postpartum women to be like
we do not have to bounce back snap back
um in any sort of particular timeline
then towards the end I was like maybe
like I really didn't like think she was
pregnant because I would have been like
so overwhelmed if by the end she's
singing Diamonds she's like over State
Farm Stadium
um and you could tell they actually they
they left her performance the cameras
like to you know move on and they came
back to her because she was like having
a moment up there like really like
taking it all in and I just thought it
was like Wow Rihanna's impressed by the
Super Bowl like that's so cool but it's
like no Rihanna is performing the Super
Bowl Halftime Show pregnant
crushing it yeah and she's on her Queen
like it was such a beautiful moment
I actually meant to I wanted to go and
watch it back now knowing that she's
pregnant because I think
if she weren't pregnant people might
want to criticize like yes what was
given yeah
um not me though I I will say no like
she was doing all the same moves after
dancers but in like you know the lighter
lesser the
you know less Energy Way which makes
sense because like she's singing they're
not of course
um and her dancing like she's such a
good dancer like the dance moves are
sick even when she's not trying it's
like she has like a Swagger she doesn't
need to do the most like her just doing
like the light versions of the
choreography is like so she's so cool so
cool like that's how like and then those
everybody be dance moves that like we
would all pick up you know because we're
not gonna dance like her dancers we're
lay people so um my initial thought like
for you you were like oh it's postpartum
belly my initial thought was like oh my
God she's pregnant and I watch like the
whole day like the pre-show and there
was like a bunch of interviews she did
like an apple music when she did a
Michael Strahan one and I realized like
she's wearing these enormous puffer
jackets slash capes and I'm like oh my
God she's been hiding this pregnancy the
whole time and like it clicked for me I
didn't want to say anything like on
social media because like it's not
appropriate and I think for the most
part like everybody did a really nice
job of like not saying respect until we
had confirmation but everyone was like a
little too respectful because she was
trying to tell us I know I know that's
the thing it's like I don't think
Rihanna meant to be unclear no I don't
think she wanted people to come away
from her Super Bowl show being like is
she pregnant oh my God she did
that pregnant so I had that experience
because the second we saw her I was like
oh my God she's pregnant and I cannot
tell you how like that carried me
through the pregnant the pregnancy
carried me through the performance like
I was so inspired like I
I've never been pregnant I've seen you
and Olivia very pregnant I know how much
it like takes a toll on your body even
if you are like the most fit queen of
all time like it's so hard and the way
her vocals stayed on point to
the very last note she did not sound or
seem out of breath was insane to me she
also I feel like and I don't know if I
Really Ever
have seen anyone else do this because
the whole time whenever anyone performs
at the Super Bowl they're like focused
just like being a performer and there
were like a couple times where like she
looked around and like took it all in
and like smiled to herself like between
songs she walked from one stage to
another and she's like smiling to
herself really taking in how big of a
deal this is obviously it's a Super Bowl
it's the biggest stage in the world but
to do it with your baby and to be
pregnant and like just to show women
like I was so inspired and like I will
not I will not say one negative thing
about it I will not tolerate one
negative thing being said about it like
could you sure will you Absa but
like knowing that she's pregnant you
really can't say anything and I I mean I
don't know how far along she is but I'm
I'm gonna guess she seemed decently like
five or six I would say between four and
five okay
um I don't know I'm just guessing which
would mean that she did the bulk of all
of this in her first trimester which is
so hard because even though the first
trimester you're not like massive you
feel horrible like you're so tired and
you're like nauseous and you just don't
have the energy to like not even just
show up to rehearsal but like to plan
like to sit in meetings like that like
and so that's what's so impressive to me
of course like the actual performance in
the stamina that she had but the fact
that like she worked on this for months
in her first trimester yeah no that's
such a good like going to rehearsals
every day and by the way it cannot be
stressed enough how amazing her dancers
were they were incredible amazing 13
minutes of non-stop Movement Like could
never be me they were doing the most for
all 13 minutes like it was so impressive
they're all so talented it was I thought
it was amazing like I loved it and I
just thought like it was so historic
like that it was just it was amazing no
it was amazing I thought the dancers
were amazing I loved the setup like when
like when she's from when she started
like better have my money and they
were all on these huge platforms I was
like this is crazy and then like
that they kept like leveling the whole
time and then of course the end but like
I thought that the whole uh just stage
setup was was brilliant but it was cool
they weren't trying too hard but it was
just like
fresh like that's like everything
Rihanna does it's like she's not so over
the top but it's just like effortlessly
cool and I thought that was like
effortlessly awesome I
completely agree I mean the moment for
Fenty Beauty like you know you don't get
paid to do that Super Bowl halftime show
and you're obviously afterwards gonna
get like ancillary money from just like
all the promo your music
um lived for it like so iconic of course
it's like the whole motion of like yeah
I'm a pregnant woman I'm fixing my
makeup in the middle of my set but also
I own this billion dollar company
like right so cool also it was for all
of the lights so like the lights are
going on so you do you do need to powder
your face uh 100 yeah extra bright I
want you all to see it oh my God didn't
even put that together this set list Ben
was for Lauren he was like Ben's
favorite song in the world
how about a round of applause and you
know what so bad I like I don't love
that song so I don't care that she
didn't sing it but I kind of love that
she didn't and I feel like maybe this is
like an easy way to bake in like a break
in your performance is to do like a
ballad like you slow down you don't have
to dance
um and she didn't do any she obviously
has like so many slow ballads that are
amazing and she didn't do any of them
she kept the energy at like a hundred
percent I knew she had so many hits but
like the way I did not realize until
they were back to back performed hit
after hit after hit like she's such a
Queen
such a queen the only ballad she did was
diamonds which was the last one oh I
didn't consider that a ballad though it
was so gorgeous like the way the whole
thing ended I was living for umbrella
like I just needed more umbrellas so
iconic like it's such a good song she
has so many good songs but I do want to
say you saw that Tick Tock of that girl
it's like she's predicting how Rihanna
should come out yep too
um lives a game but it's not fair
a breakthrough rule so I don't care
I keep doing my own thing Walking Tall
against the rain I was seeing this all
night last night I was like Levi this is
how it's gonna go
Victory is in a mile almost there don't
give a doubt the only thing that's on my
mind is Who's Gonna Run This Town
tonight like those lyrics are perfect
for the Super Bowl and once I once I had
that in my head if that's how she has to
open the show like I was really
disappointed that she didn't I know
because also even though you better have
my money it's actually probably one of
my favorite Rihanna songs ever me too
and I don't ever think about run this
town but like
uh I needed that girl yeah no that was a
really good call such a good call but
then thankfully she did sing that part
but I do like that like Rihanna didn't
waste time with like a big
um like slow opening like she has so
many hits get to it you only have so
much time before they gotta break down
that stage she was like where do we see
any time with semantics like she
literally we saw her face better
have my money yeah I love that there
were a couple songs like I mean she said
this was the hardest part was choosing
the songs and for me there were a couple
songs that are probably her biggest hits
that I didn't need to hear oh like work
oh no I'm sorry that's like such a good
decision I know that's a crazy thing to
say and no but by the way that's the
thing with the Super Bowl that's why
I've said like I do not want Taylor
Swift out here doing the halftime show
she will play my least favorite songs
Shake It Off you have to play you have
to play your most radio pop well-known
top 40 hits this is for America not for
you know the Grammys it is for people of
all ages of all backgrounds all
socioeconomic upbringings like it is for
the people and you have to do like the
radio Taylor Swift would you shake it
off love story like uh we are never
getting back together trouble
22. I don't hate it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so like you have to have that level of
expectation now I want to say a lot of
people were like Jay-Z was there she
didn't bring out Jay-Z no he's bringing
Eminem like the way that this pregnant
woman held it down by herself like I I
was so overjoyed and also like people
thought you would like not people like
my husband thought she might bring out
Drake for work because he is in he
performed in Phoenix that weekend first
of all I think she hates him she
thinks he's annoying and I feel like she
never wants their names if she can have
like she hates when their names are
always Associated together so why would
she on the biggest stage in the world
bring out this annoying guy that she
can't stand
um and he's also like her ex so like she
has like a new man and New Life Family
why would you bring him out so then when
it was all of the lights they were like
okay well now she would bring out JC if
um
if she's bringing him out and I was just
like so relieved that she did not bring
out anyone because she didn't need to
and she brought out her fetus and that
was all that mattered a hundred percent
and I feel like when they bring people
out you like don't even know that this
person is in Phoenix do you know what I
mean like Jay-Z was on the field before
we saw pictures of him in Blue Ivy like
looking really cute so we know oh my god
did you see him taking pictures for her
Obsessed the fact that he got down on
the floor which is what I make my
husband do when he's making the key shot
for me and he's just like working and
she actually was not pleased with the
work that he crashed dad trash
I love that like seeing celebrities be
human is my absolute favorite thing to
do on the planet yeah yeah it's so funny
so I love that you didn't bring anyone
out and if she had brought Jay-Z or
Drake who were both like very publicly
at the Super Bowl I would be like oh
like it's not even the surprise like
okay Eminem maybe she could have brought
out because I where the is Eminem
ever like nobody never knows where he is
yeah but I love that was he there last
year
I think so yeah I don't know I was
watching from the hospital I just give
him oh
um so
I I really I give it a 10 out of 10. I
the performance was amazing I think like
what it meant to a lot of people was
amazing I got Misty item like this
like I just I loved it I love it I know
it I'm gonna watch it again today
knowing that she's pregnant because last
night I thought she was doing it for the
postpartum mamas now I know she's doing
it for the expecting mamas but she's
really doing it for all Mamas and really
like it was the Super Bowl of The Mamas
because Rihanna and her belly yeah Mama
Kelsey and Kylie Kelsey giving birth on
the field essentially no but she didn't
get birthday treats no no no but
whenever she does go she should just
roll into the stadium and do it there
so it was really like a proud mama
moment especially considering like the
whole Sport and the whole event is for
men
no I completely agree
um are you ready for our next story a
little more entertainment news and maybe
eventually we'll talk about the game we
will I have thoughts on that too Chris
Stapleton sings A Soulful bluesy
national anthem that draws tears from
the men on the field Chris stapleton's
turn at singing the National Anthem at
Super Bowl Levi represented the third
consent consecutive year in which a
carton tree artist has sung all or part
of the Pregame Song okay last year like
Eric Church played the guitar Mickey
Guyton was 2022 and then Eric Church did
a duet with Jack with Jasmine Sullivan
yeah whatever
Chris Stapleton brought tears to the
eyes of this nation with his rendition
of the national anthem I mean I expected
nearly a single thing less than what he
gave but my God that was beautiful I
Claudia
that's that's beautiful it's very hard
for me to like not hear the national
anthem and get chills like it's just
it's what happens
um but holy like that was so
nervous
it was so spectacular I think it'll go
down as one of the best like when I
think of the best I think of Beyonce I
think of Whitney Houston
I think of Lady Gaga and I will think of
Chris Stapleton yeah it was different
he didn't stray too far but he added his
own he was a clang yeah but he was
himself
he played the guitar at the same time
which is so it was also like
effortless it was like he's playing with
his kids baseball game oh yes you know I
whenever they cut to the military it's
one thing I love about the Super Bowl is
they they really honor the troops and I
feel like there's not enough of that I
always get chills I always cry and then
they cut to the base and then they cut
to that Nick swesra guy who was crying
and I was crying oh my God I never saw
that man before in my life he's my
favorite man hot
um I was so moved by the whole it was a
really moving evening like I feel like
for a sport that's all rough and tumble
like it was very emotional between and
they you know what crazy by the way like
not to be left behind but Jason Kelsey
was misty-eyed yes he was he there was
glass in his eyes you know the NFL has
their problems but I feel like not
enough is really sad about like how much
work they do in their communities and
philanthropy and honoring the military
and I mean I will never hear the name
Pat Tillman and not just like I and you
know what
I I don't want to be negative but I fear
I must I really
um
I really had a problem with the Eagles
fans and I I don't know for sure it was
the Eagles fans But like everyone was
like yeah that was the Eagles fans in
the stadium like when they gave you know
uh the Walter
what's his name
not greed no the Dak Prescott got was it
Walter Manning I wasn't watching okay so
in the beginning they gave an award it's
Walter something Man of the Year sorry
and it's it goes to a player every year
I was about to say Walter White I think
it's Walter Payton Walter Payton okay
look at me over here they have a bunch
of nominees of players in the NFL who
win
um one of them wins for you know just
doing the most in their Community this
season you know philanthropy you know
obviously JJ Watt won it the year he did
all that for Houston
um and Dak Prescott won this year and I
know that there's like an eagles rivalry
with the uh with the Cowboys but when he
was presented as his award for
philanthropy uh he got booed by
presumably the Eagles fans and I thought
that was really disgusting
um and then for the coin toss they had
four of the Pat Tillman Scholars so
people who the Pat Tillman Foundation
have helped you know who have been in
the military and then have you know
helped them achieve higher education in
you know biotech and all different
things and they had four amazing people
like two women two men and we learned
their stories and they got to like
present the coin for the coin toss
booing why I don't know like enough
enough where is the humanity that's
crazy like you don't really pissed me
off of no but it's like it's a Pat
Tillman award have some respect
who tossed the coin
uh oh oh one of the girls she was so
cute she I'm sorry I got I got their
stories all confused but like it was all
people who like you know felt so
compelled to join the military after 9
11 much like Pat Tillman served their
time and now the foundation is helping
them you know achieve their dreams and
goals of working and whatever and the
cutest one this like little cute short
woman she got to flip the coin oh my God
I love that for her but there was like
drama in my house because we couldn't
find the remote I think Michaela hit it
and
um it's like Sex in the City when Lily
hides the cell phone so we couldn't like
turn up the volume or anything we
watched the national anthem and then we
were like oh we had we had paused to
change a diaper so we're like Zach
skipped forward so he did it on his
phone and we're sitting there for like
10 minutes and like it's bright out and
they're just like doing like pre-game
stuff and like we had rewound literally
I think Shapiro was gonna lose his mind
so we missed the coin toss but we got
back in time for the kickoff so I didn't
I wanted to see the coin yeah there was
a lot of so it's a lot to watch a Super
Bowl with babies oh my God I could never
and I was last night was I think maybe
the first night that I didn't like at
least for the first half like watch with
family or friends it was just me and Ben
on the couch and you know what so much
better especially when I have to recap
it here you were really tuned in I saw
everything I feel like a game I mean a
party someone's like talking and
and like then the commercials come and
they're like oh let's go shut up no I
was really like I had a lot going on I
took a bath in the middle oh
then I came back and I watched I watched
the end and then I watched like you know
MVP and stuff like that yeah yeah yeah
but I did miss a lot of commercials due
to all of this um and that's our next
story commercials I have thoughts okay
let's talk about best worst what are you
thinking okay before I you know give a
diatribe of like who organ like who did
what I have to say and I'm curious if
anyone else felt this way like I think
overwhelmingly as
like in a general sense I didn't
um really like the commercials I felt
like every brand was competing like who
could shove the most celebrities in in a
commercial it wasn't I feel like it used
to be about like being really funny or
different or like tugging on the
heartstrings and there were a few
commercials that did that and I will
talk about them especially if they had
dogs
um
but for the most part it was just like
let's make a biggest spectacle and
to the point where like I don't even
remember who was in what it was just
kind of like this cacophony and like
this
like just so many celebrities and it was
like oh okay and it's like if you were a
celebrity and you weren't in a
commercial like yikes yeah and I don't
know I just felt like no one really
stood out because they all did the same
thing like decently funny humor like
that little Hook was kind of funny and
they had 18 celebrities yeah agreed
there were somewhere like the
celebrities were germane to the
storyline Ben Affleck working at Dunkin
Donuts cute but then there were others
where it was just like they just kept
throwing them in yeah like so I actually
wrote down ones that I thought were cute
and they either had celebrities or
didn't okay um so the one for T-Mobile
with Bradley Cooper and his mom whereas
like we attempted to make a commercial
with Bradley Cooper and his mom and they
keep like it's basically a blooper reel
of them trying to like say T-Mobile
stuff but like his mom is so funny and
the script was really funny and I don't
know if they intended to actually make a
commercial and ended up using bloopers
or the whole concept was like blooper
very funny love seeing Bradley Cooper
He's not like an Overexposed celebrity
yeah so that was really cool and
different and I love that he did it with
his mom because his mom is like this
Philadelphia character you know with
like the hot pink lipstick like really
very good and funny cool
um a lot of commercials like recreated
iconic moments and like movie and TV
history like you know Pepsi had uh Ben
Stiller doing a lot of his iconic roles
like Zoolander and I didn't think it was
so iconic however Rakuten recreating
clueless with Amber share and Christian
siriano that was inspired yes and then
at the very end she's like Rakuten and
the guy in class behind her is like
aren't you a little old to be here and
she's like okay like it was giving Never
Been Kissed also
um that's like a good use of celebrities
because it's not like they were chosen
because they're the most famous
celebrities and they got paid millions
of dollars like I actually think they
probably got paid like reasonable
amounts but there was more of about the
story that was being told yeah and I
feel like a lot of commercials like
we're so focused on like being
outrageous or having as many celebrities
that they forgot they were selling
something and so I think a commercial
that did an amazing job was the elf face
primer one because it was Jennifer
Coolidge being crazy but the whole point
was that her hands and face were so
sticky from the very elf primer that
every time she picks something up like
it sold the product while being very
funny and you know what I use that
primer it's fantastic so
I feel like people forgot this is an
advertisement an advertisement yeah
another one that like sold the product
really well I think we saw it before the
Super Bowl though was the PopCorners
breaking breaking bread
you know what I missed that one Breaking
Bad the yeah oh my God you didn't see it
online before I tried not to watch any
before I'm like can we leave something
to the imagination oh I never even
watched Breaking Bad and I thought this
was a great commercial it made me want
to eat a popcorner but they're like
cooking up in their lab and they they
air pop a pop corner and then they're
like so excited and they go to that
dealer guy in the desert and he was like
make another flavor oh that's funny it
was it was perfect it was perfection
okay wait do you know that I watched our
toast episode from the Super Bowl two
years ago okay just like see what we
were saying it came up on like my
YouTube on my Apple TV and I said
something so funny classic me and it's
literally this I could have said this
made the same joke I said you know good
on Turbo Tax for literally paying like a
premium for a commercial like five
million dollars just to use the same
commercial the same concept that you use
on regular cable you got a budget
literally
last night I saw the Turbo Tax
commercial like nothing special nothing
different I'm like oh my God literally
the same thing yeah love the lack of
energy yeah the one for um work day
about the rock stars
I liked the concept but then they they
kind of ruined it with having so many
boxers they should have had just like
one major and have a face but see to me
that commercial was what literally the
formula that everyone followed have like
a kind of funny hook stop calling your
co-workers rock stars a thousand
celebrities like that is unoriginal now
that's what everyone does I feel like to
be different and I feel like even
somebody who did that the best was the
Doritos triangle like that was a great
concept with really A-list celebrities
But like everyone else was doing the
exact same formula I like didn't love
that also like I mean I love the
triangle and I love Doritos and I just
feel like in the past Doritos always has
the best commercials based on like humor
and Merit and like they always have like
a mouse or something not a celebrity
yeah I felt like
it wasn't the Doritos Roots you know I
agree I feel like they sold out to
Hollywood or like they went to a new
agency and they were like Jack Harlow is
the guy he'll sell your chips yeah
literally like he's on the pulse of Tick
Tock but I do have some Doritos
downstairs I bought them before the
commercial Doritos are amazing I would
like to eat them now let's talk about
something like the unknown Brands I
always love that to me the weirdest one
was basically a QR code it was like scan
for a prize now me and Ben scanned it
because we were so confused and it took
you to Twitter the Twitter of account of
a man named Gabriel
laid on I love this for him
um he is the CEO of a company called
limit break which is like a game
developer and digital daigaku which is
also like a collection of it's like a
gaming whatever so it took you to his
Twitter
and he's like running a like a giveaway
to win like a digital prize for
following him on social media so he paid
what is it what is the cost now for
commercial five million dollars seven
million dollars he I scanned it
immediately he had like 860 000 Twitter
followers he has a million now so he
paid five million dollars for 148 000
followers and I don't think for him I
don't think it was about the followers
like it was about like the Intrigue and
I think so many people scanned it I why
would you follow him like just it was
nfts it's nfts yeah I think it's about
Intrigue and awareness like and that's
pretty cool like but I don't think he
was doing it for followers because I'm
sure his feed is not that interesting he
was doing it for like the Intrigue I
know but they should have like literally
taken that QR code to their website or
something
yeah I don't know I can't begin to
understand nft people me neither
um
commercial
you know who had a big night
let me Jesus
oh what the was that Jesus had so
many commercials he has a lot of money
Jesus has a ton of money and they were
like they were well done they weren't
like your typical you know they were
like powerful yeah yeah like there was
some sort of like director with a vision
board and I thought that was weird I you
know
Jesus is a cool guy and stuff but like I
just didn't know like he had commercials
I know well I thought overall you know
the message was was nice like I have no
issue but I just like who's paid for
that no Beyond Jesus Jesus
Jesus himself wait also totally said
track but in the performances we forgot
to talk about Cheryl Lee Ralph from
Abbott Abbott Elementary yeah who um
sang really beautifully but when she was
singing I was like is she lip syncing
and then by the end I was like no she's
not then she uh responded to the
questioning of her lip singing abilities
and she said does it matter does it
matter no thank you so she lip said yes
so Olivia was saying that everybody lip
syncs like they just that is what they
have to do to do the Super Bowl they
don't want any surprises but like I
don't believe Chris Stapleton would sign
up for lip syncing no and honestly she
like flubbed up the lip sync a little
bit in the beginning she did and then
the rest was Flawless so I was like oh
maybe I was just seeing stuff
no I think she lip sync and I I have no
problem with that because as long as
it's like you on the original yeah it's
the biggest like performance in the
world like let's get it right like I
think there were some people saying that
Rihanna lip sync no
I don't care either way because I
understand this is a television program
like you're entertaining you have to do
what you have to do like maybe it
doesn't make sense to have her audio
like how does it go through to the
television and also to the uh I actually
I know that there are Live Events like
the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade like
you are lip syncing no matter what
there's no if sounds or Bots for the
last 10 years people don't even try to
pretend anymore it's literally
fraudulent they like always forget that
the track starts and they're like
but I don't I actually do not believe
that for the Super Bowl like I've
watched I know I didn't believe it when
Olivia said it either half to lip sync
Olivia is 100 you have to listen for
your life I think if you want to they're
open to it and if you want to not
they're open to that as well yeah
and I think even if things do go awry
like
it's actually good for business and
ratings like when there's a moment that
everyone's talking about I I don't I
don't believe it like and I think in
Super Bowl's past like you've seen
celebrities like get out of breath on
stage like it's real yeah
I I don't believe it Olivia's wrong
agreed but I do think that Cheryl Lee
Ralph lip sync over yourself me too and
I have no issue with that no we know she
can sing like she literally just sang
her award show
acceptance speech like we know she can
sing
um more commercials that were Good Will
Ferrell for GM and Netflix okay it was
okay it was cute it was it was crazy
nothing really stood out to me oh
except I want to shout out I feel like
you know all the brands that that get
the commercials are
these like old school been around 500
years Ford you know Procter Gamble and
delay to see new like direct to Consumer
very like digitally built companies
getting commercials it was like you know
yes and the farmer's dog which is that
dog food company that we actually use
um to see them get a spot was amazing
and it was so did you see it it's like I
watched it I watched it this morning and
I was not okay because I had heard like
some good things about it and I was
reading like listicles of best ads so
that we could talk about them because I
know I missed a lot and I was literally
crying I was like this is not gonna work
for me no it was so beautiful like
really I loved it it was
like I have such a positive brand
Association now like it was really good
marketing gorgeous and like I I you want
your dog
to be eating food that's gonna make him
around forever it's it's a plus b equals
c not stock no it was so good and I feel
like if you want a good Super Bowl
commercial like just have a dog in it
because then I think it was Amazon who
had another one that really
played with me because they have this
dog and every time the family goes to
work the dog tears apart the house
because he's so upset and bored and he
misses his family and it gets really bad
you know the guys can't use the remote
the remote is all chewed up the lamp is
broken and so they go to Amazon and they
buy like a big kennel
to you know transport a dog and we're
like oh my God they're getting
rid of this dog with them what kind of
commercial is this so they bring
the kennel into the house and they open
it and there's another dog a friend so
he's not bored at home it was really an
emotional roller coaster me and Ben
looked at each other we're like what the
they're getting rid of the dog
oh my God but it was beautiful that's so
beautiful yeah
look at Amazon just when you think you
know them
um unlimited money is really an amazing
thing to have no but all these brands
have unlimited money and some of them
gave us crap so true that commercial I
want to say was T-Mobile again with John
Travolta I think his name is Zach Braff
I get him confused yeah um and
my favorite actor of all time from
Clueless
I thought it was really bad like I
thought that was a perfect example of
like let's just throw some crappy
celebrities and a song and make a
commercial like do less I dare you yeah
agreed or just like choose one celebrity
make a choice like say T-Mobile like
we're the John John Travolta is the face
of T-Mobile not yes Bradley Cooper
Donald faiza and John Travolta and Zach
Braff and by the way this is a great
segue into our ad because you know who
did a great job with that with just one
celebrity
who Squarespace
and and the whole slogan of like a
website that makes websites I thought it
was very cute and funny and it had one
major celebrity not a million Adam
Driver I thought it was great and I'm
excited to tell you more about
Squarespace because maybe you didn't see
the commercial last night or maybe you
didn't understand what squareskies can
do for you from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business Adam Driver said it
best Squarespace is a website that makes
websites so whether you have a side
hustle uh you want to get into
e-commerce you want to start a business
Squarespace is an amazing resource if
you don't know how to create a website
which most people do not I've made many
websites over the years like doing my
blogs and stuff and I've always used
Squarespace it is a fabulous tool that
makes it so easy to build something that
looks like really high-end but you do
not need to be a software engineer they
also have amazing
um tools to use once you get your
website up and running like e-commerce
they have video blocks you can connect
your social media accounts you can get a
traffic overview into all your analytics
you also own all the content that you
put on Squarespace as a platform they
offer a one-click data portability they
also have multiple contributors so you
can give contributors selective access
to your sites website manager depending
on their permission so if you have
people who work for you they can get
into the website create their own logins
um
Squarespace is really your One-Stop shop
for all things website all things
e-commerce especially if you don't have
like a background in that sort of thing
um they are the place to sell anything
they have the tools you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has merchandising features
to make your products look at their best
online so check out squarespace.com
toast for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain that's
squarespace.com toast and offer code
toast
thank you turd you're welcome I'm glad
you like that commercial I did and I was
um hoping we had a Squarespace ad today
so I could talk about it in a really
native way that's so perfect oh we
should have like lined up all of our ads
State Farm
for the State Farm Stadium State
Farmer's dog
Synergy then all right
um okay our next story fourth Story the
game the game
the Kelsey Bowl it was Kelsey vs Kelsey
and I really in terms of the Kelsey vs
Kelsey I was rooting for the Eagles like
I and I've actually after last night
like I
kind of like off on Travis Kelsey like I
think he's kind of annoying okay I know
I I really liked his post game interview
I thought he was hysterical I
actually didn't like
it was Patrick mahomes's post game
interview and like Travis was right next
to him and like literally he didn't
Latin did not let Patrick Mahomes speak
like he was just like being crazy and I
know he was like hyped and excited and
like kind of being like an attention
and I'm like okay like he was also
like giving all the praise back to
Patrick but like what yes he like first
of all he he's keeping the mic and he
just screamed into it yeah and then he
was like none of you said that the
chiefs were gonna win not one of you
next time you talk about the Chiefs put
some respect on our name and I'm like
honestly that's so true like
even we never thought that they were
gonna win and like next time we talk
about the Chiefs like we should put some
respect on their name yeah but like
Jason to me is like the PJ like when you
see Jason is the All-American man like
the family man Jason has said like he
does not do that like pre-game fashion
show everyone shows up in Louis Vuitton
I mean if you saw Travis Kelsey's outfit
he wore this enormous Louis Vuitton
trench coat with a matching Louis
Vuitton duffel bag it's really like a
fashion show uh Jason Kelsey showed up
in literally a t-shirt from his high
school and black basketball shorts and
like a black duffel bag he's so just
like low-key down to earth like I really
in terms of the Brethren like I was
rooting for Jason I think he's so
precious like he's not fancy and of
course like the second Travis got on the
field he scored a touchdown and they cut
to Jason eating a protein bar and the
announcer was like one brother is
scoring and the other brothers having a
snack and it's like Daddy we are all
Jason Kelsey we are all Jason Kelsey but
you know what like you're either Jason
or Travis and you're either a Jason
Gurley or a Travis girly and I know so
many like ladies out there and men too
probably like are in love with Travis
Kelsey like he's so cute he's got that
Charisma
um and I definitely started out like the
scales just because they knew Travis
more he's more front-facing he did the
show and then the more I got to know
Jason the scales were tipped no and it's
like okay if you had to spend a romantic
evening with Jason or Travis who would
you spend it with because I suspended
with Jason I would spend it with Jason I
don't think I have the the patients for
Travis and his energy by the way were
you the one who told me that you read
somewhere online that Travis was rumored
to be dating Zuri Hall yeah from E yeah
I did read that I read that like not on
you know some like random websites but
like they got that from somewhere I know
every rumor like has an origin so I ship
and I hope it's true me too
uh but
oh so so when it came to the Brethren I
was rooting for the Eagles but when it
came to like the teams I was rooting for
the Chiefs you know and I think an
Eagles fan would tell you this like you
know other teams like they don't like
the eagles and I'm just like
I just find their fan base like toxic
I'm sorry I don't want to like
everyone's coming no it's like I wanted
the Eagles as a team to win but I didn't
want their fans to feel Joy
but I also didn't want them to feel pain
they're just so extreme they're so
extreme honestly I just feel like it's
best for everyone if they don't make the
Super Bowl because it's like when they
win it's bad when they lose it's bad
it's like it's a lose-lose yeah I agree
but I also do like what I've learned
about the eagles which is like they're
the villains of the NFL everybody hates
them and they don't care and I do love
that mentality me too
um but you know when the villains lose
it's like hahaha you know so
especially after an amazing game like at
different points you didn't know who was
gonna win everyone kept scoring there
was a really good football played I mean
I know sometimes there's a Super Bowl
and people watching me like this is not
a good Super Bowl I'm like what do you
mean it's a football game no but like
sometimes it's I felt last night how it
was gonna win the whole time yeah last
night was good football I believe yeah I
mean there was two minutes left and it
was 35 35 like that's a game yeah we
have a game the whole time when it's
like a blowout in the second half
there's like literally a 15 Point
deficit like that's boring yeah there
were very few errors except the Eagles
had one error that kind of cost them the
game yeah so a lot of people are like
quaking over this one call that the refs
made that gave him a five-point penalty
and really into like the goal Zone uh
for the Chiefs one of the players was
you know penalized for holding it was
like a very loose call I mean it could
have been let go it wasn't like the
biggest holding in the world it was like
very innocuous but I don't really
believe it's fair to say like they would
have won if it weren't for this one call
like there's 45 minutes of playing like
you had 45 minutes to to win
yeah I didn't see the call that was when
I was in the bath um so I didn't realize
that the error was made on what could
have been a call that could go either
way but it's like did he hold maybe it's
like not the worst hole but it holds a
hold yeah and he still did that check
holding was helding yeah something
something was held yeah so like okay
maybe like he didn't have to make the
call like if he didn't want to but right
he yelled yeah and you know it was a
triumphant night for Patrick Mahomes
he's had this like ankle injury the
whole season and it really he got
tackled really bad in the second quarter
um he came back in the second half like
ready to go he was like limping
a little bit but he didn't care like he
will take care of his body tomorrow he
gave his all including his angle to the
game and it paid off it was really good
football by everyone like Jalen hurts
played amazing I mean there were a
couple throws that were like so far
down the field yeah there was
some Insanity there were a lot of really
great plays which I think is what you
look for in a Super Bowl great catches
you know I mean the turnover the
turnover the Eagles turned over the ball
and the Chiefs player picked it up and
scored a touchdown I mean that's bad
yeah that was bad that's exciting I was
very exciting and you know I really feel
like it wasn't one person's game I know
they really have to give the MVP to the
quarterback and he should because he led
the team he's like the captain whatever
but sometimes like someone makes a play
that changes the game it was that
defensive guy who scored a touchdown
that was amazing and I really didn't
feel like it was like just Travis
Kelsey's night like I think he scored
once like I think everyone from the
offense to the defense like everybody
pulled their weight and it was really
and that's when a team is at their best
there's not just one star doing
everything everybody did their best I
think we all did our best exactly and I
feel that way for the Eagles too but you
know there has to be a winner and there
had to be a loser and the Chiefs won
which I'm happy for the Chiefs and it
was it was an upset a little bit yeah it
was and you know the footage we got on
the field of the Kelsey family reuniting
was tough we saw Jason just kind of
collapse into his mother's arms which
was so sad we saw Travis and Jason give
a big hug and Jason was like don't worry
about me just go celebrate like we'll
talk later
um we saw his dad come over to Travis
and be like like you have two rings
Jason has one a little you know sibling
rivalry oh that's I was wondering where
the dad was because all this Focus has
been on Mama Kelsey as it should as his
Chad was there as a trip it to the that
I meant last night when I was falling
asleep to Google where if the dad is in
the picture is Donna widowed yeah yeah I
know something I was like I was gonna
search just like Kelsey father because I
hadn't heard a peep out of him he was
saying well we know like what John is
wearing what she had for breakfast what
she made for the boys
with her sneakers her coat her purse
what's in her purse oh Jackson was on
the field making tick tocks I saw it I
made the one about um if you beat a cash
imma be a fuse boom yeah I saw he was
doing that he was having fun obsessed
like he's in the background footage of
all of um the interviews just like you
know dabbing it up doing the Lil Uzi you
know I love it yeah I also think Phoenix
was a great host for the Super Bowl I
thought it was cool that that Waste
Management golf tournament was okay the
worst like everyone in town got to go to
that and then go to that but there was a
lot of controversy about the field what
do you mean oh my God people were
slipping the whole night yeah so and
apparently the person who's like laid
the grass you know the grass is grown in
a special whatever it takes years it
costs eight hundred thousand dollars the
grass and the groundskeeper who's been
is that Super Bowl grass or just State
Farm Stadium girl I believe Super Bowl
okay so the guy who's been laying the
grass who's been in charge of it he's 94
he calls himself The Sod father
um this was his last game I'm obsessed
okay and I don't I really don't think
the grass like was his fault
wait where is Theo oh right next to me
okay
um I don't think it was his fault so the
NFL painted on top of the grass that big
ugly logo with all those colors they and
so that was really the slipperiest part
the center and a lot of times where the
kickers had to kick
and it was spoken about in the press
conference a lot a lot of the players
especially from the Eagles who were
bitter they were like it was literally
unacceptable like this is the National
Football League it's the Super Bowl like
figured out people were slipping and
sliding all over it was like a slip
inside
damn I didn't see that and that's really
frustrating but all I'll say is that at
least like both teams had it equally you
know everyone was getting in the same
conditions yeah so but you'll see like
guys made catches and like started to
run they had more time but they slipped
um there was a lot of slipping inside
and the Eagles player in the first half
all changed their cleats
wow yeah they were like trying to adjust
oh maybe what Phoenix wasn't the best
host no although the weather was
probably gorgeous
yeah I like a weather where it's like
not one team has the weather Advantage
because they're used to playing in the
snow where they're used to play like so
I felt like it was really neutral
territory and everyone who I felt on
Instagram who was there like seemed like
they had a great having a great time
yeah it was awesome it was honestly it
was a great Super Bowl from the
performances to the game to the
commercial like it was really enjoyable
it was a great Super Bowl I agree yeah
okay so let's talk about our fifth and
final story then which is uh some celeb
news and really the only celeb news from
the weekend because Megan Fox and
machine are Making Waves after she
deleted her Instagram hours after
hinting at a split
Megan Fox is removing her online
presence at least for the moment the
actress deleted her Instagram account on
Sunday afternoon hours after she shared
a post on the social media platform it
hinted at a possible breakup between
herself and machine gun in the post she
uploaded a series of photos of herself
in a video of an envelope being burned
in a fire pit she captioned It with
lyrics from Beyonce's 2016 album
lemonade writing you can taste the
dishonesty it's all over your breath
uh
uh and then she like unfollowed everyone
except for like three hot shots
with me gun but then she deleted her
Instagram too right so here's what I'll
say I don't know if they're broken up I
don't really care like I feel like when
these two got together we were like
obsessed like total ship and it really
was like this kind of perfect
relationship they're so compatible and I
think it was also really good for both
of their careers like Megan Megan Kelly
Megan Fox was like you know kind of
brought into like this new younger
generation Machine Gun Kelly was kind of
validated as like a major Hollywood
Superstar I thought it was really
beneficial and then I stopped caring
because they got like freaky and weird
yeah and they just like showed up places
like licking each other in the blood
like I don't know I'm not into that like
satanic so I just I stopped caring
so I'll just I nothing will change if
these two are together or if this is
just some drama which I feel like
they're always like starting stuff like
especially over the last few weeks and
months there's been a lot of rumors that
they've been splitting you know she
posted like looking for a girlfriend and
people were like oh my God she's single
and then they're together and they're
going to like major words together like
they're very together they were just at
the Grammys together like
they're so I kind of feel like this is
like more nonsense from them not like PR
or anything but I just think like
they're very intense people like even
the way that they love each other and
then they do the thing from like
Bewitched and do each other's hands like
yeah they get into a fight and they
delete each other's pictures from
Instagram doesn't mean they're broken up
and she's gonna make him jealous by
following like a bunch of guys right but
like they're just intense people I can't
relate so I don't understand I shall
wait for a statement or confirmation I'm
not gonna pretend to understand the
inner workings of this couple right you
said that dumwa said that they're still
very much together yeah not that that is
any sort of confirmation but like I like
I literally like I don't care
yeah though you're the one who insisted
we talk about it today just want to make
that out there oh yeah yeah by the way
yeah I actually wasn't going to because
I knew that you weren't going to Care no
but like
we had to talk about it ever literally
and I was surprised how everyone's like
what like who you care
I like I find that shocking I feel like
when they first started dating like you
were gonna find me caring I really cared
especially the Brian Austin Green Shadow
Moakler like the whole thing like I was
obsessed now that it's fizzled and
they're like are engaged and like I like
I don't care yeah
and if they're both back on the market
great like I'll have some fun with them
on our list
yeah but it's gonna they're gonna be
hard to place after all this yeah no
they really are like Kindred freaky
Spirits yeah they're they're attack
they're bonded for life I mean they did
a bloody blood yeah
so I don't know like would you want to
date someone who's has a blood pack with
someone else how do you end one
that's such a good question would I want
to date someone who is a blood pact with
someone else no and it's not because I
would be like sad that they have this
like you know you Union with someone
else and be like you shared blood you're
disgusting like I would just think that
they're gross yeah and I would just be
like you know that's level of intensity
you're never gonna get with me and I
don't want to disappoint you so yeah for
you this relationship is all downhill
because I'm not doing any of that
like but maybe they came to you because
they were tired of that life I don't
want to be someone somebody's Refuge
from like a freaky life
right agreed yeah so you know what me
and me and me gun it's not a match
damn I'll let him know yeah enter
so that was a Super Bowl recap that was
so fun I love the Super Bowl I can't
wait for next year go Niners
go who do you want to see next year even
though I have no idea who's in the other
league
yeah like all of my teams are in this
league this league so I don't know and
you know it's everything changes people
get traded this is like the time of year
where you know a team can go from being
like a major threat to a nobody or
nobody can go from being a nobody to a
major threat so we got to see who gets
traded I hope everything stays copacetic
at the Niners I think they got something
really good you know Christian and Brock
I don't know what they're gonna do about
the quarterback but they've got Kyle
they've got Kristen like I think as long
as they stick together I think they have
real potential I mean they made it to
the game before the Super Bowl I think
they're a little messy you know
especially the Super Bowl thing the
quarterback thing was like a little you
know chaotic I think I'll just sort some
things out
and I think it'll be good yeah
I think so too
go Niners go Niners go everyone go team
go
yeah and you know what what I was
thinking last night like no matter where
you're from like I just the whole time I
was thinking like to reach the Pinnacle
of your career already having made the
NFL which is a huge accomplishment how
proud your families must be how much of
an inspiration you are to those in your
community I know there was you know a
bunch of winners and losers last night
but really to make to the Super Bowl is
such an accomplishment and everybody
should really feel so proud of
themselves and I just know that like
their family was in the stands and
watching at home feeling so proud of all
the players have accomplished and that's
really the takeaway it honestly is win
or lose it is yeah sure also teams had
won semi recently so it wasn't like
there was one team that hasn't won since
the 90s the Cowboys and we're all
filling for them so it wasn't like sad
for anyone really so true
so I didn't feel sad thankfully
thankfully because I have my nachos did
you see them I did your food looked so
good after like me in bed just like
ordered it and like got snacks from girl
puff and like you had this like Catered
Affair catered by Moi uh my nachos were
so good I definitely recommend that
recipe sheet pan nachos from the
Magnolia table cookbook it can't be
found online but someone did take a
picture of the cookbook and put it on
Pinterest
um gorgeous so if you really like don't
want to get the cookbook it is kind of
big uh
it was so tasty I need to make nachos
more often but now football season's
over yikes there's only two more months
there's like not a long break in
football
no it comes back in the fall
yeah it comes back in the fall and
everybody's like desperate for it but
there was literally a commercial that
was like the
news the preseason I don't know it
literally said don't worry we'll be back
in two months like you'll be fine I saw
a commercial for it anyone else know
what I'm talking about no football isn't
they went down the length of a football
field and the football field had text on
it and it literally said two months
well that would be new
like football's in the fall okay but
you're right like they don't play in the
summer no no you're 100 right but
baseball's year round literally
literally
so that is our super toast recap that is
our show thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere podcast can be found
at Spotify iTunes Stitch our public
radio I have radiocast box all the
places wherever you listen to podcasts
find us that tell us about five star
review about a beautiful setting and
smart we are everyone please wish me
luck on my big New York Fashion oh my
God good luck attorney you're gonna be
amazing I wish you were there it's
honestly not gonna be the same without
you I'll make the stats or send me vids
and I think there's a live stream I I
think I'm not sure so just check mine
there definitely is yeah I feel like
there is get the link post it to your
Gram I will I will I love you guys have
an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
for Tuesday for Tuesday Valentine's Day
Jackie will you be mine I'm already
yours turdy heart soul I'm already
Harry's so I can't be yours sorry oh
wench
love you guys bye love you bye